what's going on guys today we're going
over the spoilers for my academia
chapter 295
which is the last chapter of 2020. in
this one we got the reveal of the fourth
user of one for us quirk
which is about like the millionth reveal
we've had this arc now and we also have
the return of the all f1 vestige
and seemingly the end of the battle i've
put a link in the description so you can
read the spoilers that i use for this
video
but bear in mind that more translations
will come out later today
and on sunday which will you know
clarify a few things without further ado
don't forget to sub for more videos like
this
and yeah let's just get into it the
chapter kicks off with deku lying on the
ground
having just woken up from being
unconscious as he pulls his body up
the panel shows us how his left arm is
just totally wrecked
as it just hangs by his side in a really
gross way he looks over at todoroki and
is relieved to see that his friend is
alive but then midoriya feels a sharp
and painful sensation
in his mind he describes this sensation
as something stabbing at his head
and we see a jolt of lightning appear
which has previously appeared before
when he was fighting against all for one
this sensation that he's previously felt
before was the fourth user of one for
all's quirk
with this quirk deku can immediately
sense nearby danger
which you know when you combine that
with his black whip ability he's
basically the next spider-man
from what we know so far this quirk is a
sort of danger detection
which will allow deku to know when
things are approaching him and it will
also tell him when other people are in
danger
previously in the manga all might told
midoriya how he was only human
and that there were occasions when he
couldn't save people but obviously if
deku has this quirk that's constantly
telling him about people in danger
then you know he's he's never gonna get
a moment's rest he's constantly gonna be
on the front line trying to save lives
we know that all might previously
withheld details about the fourth user
one for all
because he was worried for deku and you
know i thought this would be i thought
the reveal would be more
interesting than what it is but still
you know it's a decent quirk
um but yeah that's pretty much all i
have to say on it to be honest
moving on lemelian quickly punches mr
compress who was
already pretty damaged after that last
chapter mr cobras thinks to himself how
he wanted to buy some more time before
the heroes got to him because shiguraki
needs longer to wake up
only once shigaraki wakes up can the no
move be fully controlled
which of course would totally change the
situation in favor of the villains
if shigaraki is controlling them as
myrio approaches spinner and shiguraki
to knock them out
shiggy awakens at just the right moment
and unleashes his radio waves quirk
earlier in the war we saw shiguraki use
radio waves combined with air cannon
and you know he does this again to blast
muriel and the rest of the heroes away
the radio waves also send a message to
the nomu so yeah it kinda has two
functions pushing the heroes away
and also letting the nomu know what to
do shiguraki then stands up
but we can see that it's all for one
who's controlling his body again
and not shigaraki himself the gnome we
begin to rush towards shiguraki and
spinner with the intention of flying
away
and from the leaks we have currently it
seems like all for one is actually going
to leave giganto marquia behind
as well as leaving toge behind and mr
compress we know that giganto marquia
doesn't really do much if he hasn't been
given orders
so the heroes will be able to restrain
him at least also in case you're
wondering about where dabi and skeptic
are
mr compressed turned them both into a
marble and it's implied that he then
threw that marble into spinner's scarf
so darby and skeptic are safe and they
are with shigaraki and spinner
as they try to escape as the nomus grab
shigaraki and spinner and begin to leave
the remaining heroes desperately tried
to stop them
with midoriya using black whip from his
mouth again to get inches away from
shigaraki
afo tells midoriya that once shigaraki's
body is complete then they shall meet
again
before using air cannon to forcefully
push midoriya away
as deku is falling to the ground he
thinks that while shigaraki has done
some unforgivable things
when they were in the vestige world it
looked like shigeraki wanted to be saved
this is a very interesting comment and
perhaps a little bit of foreshadowing
that shigaraki you know may not be fully
evil by the end of this series
um i actually did a theory about that
which you should check out but yeah
it's kind of implied from deku's
statement that there's something still
there that shigaraki
can still uh be taken away from the
darkness
with that said the nomu fly off into the
distance with shigeraki and spinner
and uh yeah the war arc finally comes to
an end we see bakugo collapsed on the
ground
as many of the heroes arrive on the
scene just as shiguraki escapes
the war arc has been an incredible ride
with tons of twists and turns
but i think this was the right time for
it to come to an end hero society has
been irreparably damaged
and you know ue high school might not be
able to survive everything that's just
happened
it could go a lot of different ways from
here but it all depends on how
safe horukoshi wants to play it thanks
for watching this video as always
and while i do have more videos planned
over the holidays there won't be another
chapter review or reaction
until 2021 and that includes twitch as
well so i won't be streaming on twitch
for chapter reviews until the new year
until then stay safe and have a great
holiday season
peace out